eine these heute abend des corona test
fiasko muss aufgearbeitet werden die
bürger test sind ja ab ersten juli
eigentlich immer kosten bis zum ersten
juni immer kostenlos gewesen jetzt
werden sie aber kostenpflichtig außerdem
ausnahmefall der grund
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
sagte im zdf dass man sich die tests
nicht mehr leisten könne laut lauterbach
lagen die ausgaben teilweise bei einer
milliarde pro monat ich möchte die leute
gar nicht darüber debattieren ob im test
jetzt sinnvoll sind oder waren
wie es weitergehen sollte mir geht es um
das mangelnde unternehmertum der politik
die milliarde pro monat kommt auch
zusammen beim missbrauch mit unserem
steuergeld betrieben wurde jeder konnte
ein testcenter gründen es war nicht nur
ärzte oder apotheker geführt hat jeder
ein testzentrum aufgemacht und die
anzahl der angeblich durchgeführten
tests konnten am anfang per strichliste
notiert werden das hat uns ja auch ein
apotheker vor wenigen tagen erzählt ohne
personalien das ist kein scherz
ermittler gehen von einem schaden durch
erfundene test von mehr als einer
milliarde euro aus kontrollen der
privaten test betriebe waren anfangs von
der regierung nicht vorgesehen das
änderte sich erst als wdr ndr und sz
über den fall mehdi kaan berichteten der
test am betreiber aus bochum hat
gestanden erfundene test abgerechnet zu
haben der schaden soll allein in diesem
fall 25 millionen euro betragen auch der
für die tests gezahlte preis war vor
allem am anfang meiner meinung nach zu
hoch der bund zahlte den betreibern von
testzentren 11 eur 50 protest drei euro
fünfzig pauschale für den test selbst
und acht euro für weitere kosten die
anfallen auch der apothekerverband
nordrhein geht von preisen um die 20
euro aus wenn lauterbach also sagt wir
können uns die kostenlosen test nicht
mehr leisten muss ja nicht vor allem
sagen wir haben einen wahnsinnig
schlechten job gemacht und damit ist
meine erste frage heute an ihren sparen
ob ich vielleicht zu schaffen ob meine
these stimmt oder wieder ist mit den
test ab lief also zuerst einmal und
deswegen werde ich nicht viel dazu sagen
habe ich ein einfaches prinzip wussten
nicht dass sie so viel krone heute
machen ich äußere mich nicht zu
aktuellen kroner politik weil ich finde
das macht man nicht ich finde das bringt
auch deutschland nicht weiter wenn
minister ihre nachfolger ex minister
ihre nachfolger kommentieren oder
umgekehrt deswegen bin ich da sehr
zurückhaltend was aktuell
nichts mehr
ich kann halt nur 1 nochmal
grundsätzlich sagen das ist ein gutes
jahr her dass sollte halt natürlich über
über nacht mehr oder weniger eine test
infrastruktur entstehen kostenlose tests
eine ausnahme aus einer welle heraus
sollte uns das führen und dinge die
schnell ändern sie haben sich
entscheiden soll es perfekt sein aber
schnell gehen kann man natürlich im
studio ein jahr später sagen das hätte
anders und so ist alles okay akzeptiere
ich auch aber es sollte halt ziemlich
schnell gehen und es sollte
flächendeckend seien selbst in meinem
heimatdorf im münsterland bei meinen
eltern 3700 einwohner gab es der
teststationen
und viele deutsche haben habe ich schon
die erfahrung gemacht ist das eigentlich
schon angenehm einfach war diesen test
zu machen
und wenn sie jetzt über die kosten reden
ich meine der test das personal die
textstelle das kostet halt auch und
wurde sehr klar gesagt wenn ihr das
irgendwie halbiert konnte das gleich
ganz vergessen jetzt gar keine anbieten
also die frage wie viel würde man einen
80 millionen deutsche ein test kommt
streiten ab 12 euro oder 15 euro wenn
jeder wenn jeder nur einmal die woche im
test macht statistisch und viele haben
in den wellen auf 2.345 manche tägliche
test gemacht was alles möglich war und
ok dann kommen halt diese summen die
hoch sind aber im zweifel zum lockdown
und den kosten eines lockt bei uns dann
immer doch noch einmal anders dann
kommen diese summen zusammen mir wenn
ich einmal noch mal nachhaken darf ich
versteh ich finde es sogar sympathisch
dass sie nicht über ihr nachfolger
sprechen wollen ich finde das wirklich
angenehm weil ich finde das nachtreten
auch nicht gut aber
wenn mich auch mal treibt gehen wo sie
dafür verantwortlich meinte behälter
lauterbach neben wir oft genug sehen sie
denn jetzt nicht rückblicken dass sie
sagen vielleicht hätte man es nur
apotheker und ärzte durchführen lassen
sollen oder vielleicht hätten wir noch
mehr auf den betrug machen sollen
manchmal gibt es ja auch eine
selbstreflexion wo man jetzt sagt naja
bei den test hätten wir auch das eine
oder andere besser machen könnte man im
nachhinein auch manches aber sie sind
ich werde ich das gesehen haben die
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen haben
gerade gesagt unter den bedingungen
werden sie diese tests nicht mehr
abrechnen also werden sie nicht mehr
toten weil weil das einfach nicht mehr
geht so ist halt die frage alle die
jetzt dann sagen da muss man irgendwie
es anderen so einfach ist das gar nicht
ist irgendwie anders zu machen wo es gar
keine direkte beziehung des
bundesministeriums zu apotheke wir haben
keine finanz beziehung wo das
ministerium irgendwie an die apotheken
was auszahlt sondern es hat alles eben
eben seine wege klar kann man immer was
anders machen aber ich sage ihnen wenn
die tests nur in apotheken und
arztpraxen stattgefunden hätten hätten
meine eltern mich nicht in ihrem dorf
keine testangebot gehabt aber herr
sparen sie verstehen dass ich mich über
die strichliste gewundert und auch
geärgert habe als bürgerin als ich
gehört habe man musste konnte einfach
strichlisten machen oder am anfang
musste man nicht mal als die personalien
für den der den test also wurde der test
durchgeführt wurde aufnehmen da habe ich
mich schon geärgert als bürgerin muss
ich ihnen ehrlich sagen bei allem
respekt davor und sie haben recht es im
studio immer leichter ist darüber zu
reden deswegen bin ich auch journalisten
und nicht politikerin ich gebe mir
ehrlich zu aber das mit der strichliste
sagen es war der versuch und damit mehr
ich dazu jetzt mehr ja wenn es so leicht
wäre das system zu ende dann hätte herr
meier mit der ampel koalition ja im
dezember ist geändert ich meine seine
leidenszeit als er mich exakt acht
monaten gilt das system fort weil es
offensichtlich nicht ganz so einfach ist
ist einfach zu ändern aber das ist jetzt
das ist jetzt ein bisschen einfach
ersparen auch wenn sie jetzt dazu nichts
mehr sagen wollen dass also das test
chaos das reizt ich ja was die gesamte
corona politik ein in ganz andere auch
dem ich will das gar nicht über 2g 3g
schule zu et cetera diskutieren da kommt
nachher zu aber masten beschaffungs
chaos test chaos impfstoff beschaffungs
chaos und bei all diesen themen haben
sie als zuständiger minister die
zentrale verantwortung und ich glaube
beantworten doch schon die ampel besser
geworden er sage ich gleich aber ich
möchte schon da weil sie eben erklärt
haben das alles natürlich nicht einfach
und profan ist wie man so ein fest
organisiert dass sie alles richtig aber
den ersten test verordnungen genau quasi
die
notwendigkeit der überprüfung von test
center betreibern nicht drin ist dann
ist das original ihr politisches
verantwortlich man muss ja nicht so
extrem sein wie in berlin das dann also
auch
gesuchte mit taktgefühl haftbefehl
gesuchte personen im testcenter
aufmachen können aber die politische
verantwortung dafür haben sie und was
wir jetzt gemacht haben ist in der tat
zu sagen
wir können uns diese tests infrastruktur
in dieser form nicht mehr leisten
deswegen haben wir jetzt eine
kostenbeteiligung eingeführt das ging
nicht sofort das war 3 euro muss jetzt
eine ausnahme sehr genau dass wir hätten
uns da als fdp durchaus euro mehr
vorstellen können auch was die
länderbeteiligung angeht weil warum muss
der bund immer alles übernehmen das
gehört ja auch dazu dass in dieser
pandemie situation der bund eigentlich
alles übernommen hat während die länder
sich dann sehr schlanken den
bundesländern sehr schlanken fuß gemacht
haben und so glaube ich kommt man im
ergebnis zu einem deutlich fairen
lastenausgleich ist es ja nicht so dass
die bürger nur über die bürger tests
sich testen millionen von menschen
testen sich täglich freiwillig weil sie
sich ein test in der apotheke oder im
internet bestellt haben und haben damit
den ersten schnelltest der glaube ich an
vielen stellen bestimmt genauso
effizient ist
mach das mal etwas zeit nur acht monate
genau aber ich würde ja gesagt 1 da bin
ich nicht verstehen bleibt es konnte
sich niemand einfach selbst zur
testzentrum erklären auch schon zu
beginn nicht sondern es musste das
gesundheitsamt vor ort in einem
offiziell die genehmigung geben dafür
dass man ein testzentrum ist und das ist
im föderalen staat so
gründeten die bundes ist ganz normales
handeln das macht jede bundesregierung
auch die von ihnen getragene da wir
keine verwaltung in der fläche haben
dass man aufgaben festlich die vor ort
umgesetzt werden ist es ganz normales
föderales handeln und es war und ist
aufgabe der behörden vor ort den
testzentren eine wenn man es so nennen
will genehmigung dafür zu geben dass sie
überhaupt abrechnen dürfen und ich hatte
unterstellt ja und das würde ich auch
bis heute unterstellen wollen zumindest
man wird ja nicht zuletzt in berlin
immer öfter eines besseren belehrt dass
bevor man eine textstelle genehmigt sie
sich mal anschaut die räumlichkeiten zum
beispiel an schaut sich das personal
anschaut anschaut was da gemacht werden
soll es sind aber dass alle angeschaut
wurden natürlich in berlin ist es
offenkundig nicht der fall so aber das
ist das ist weder ein miteinander das
kann man hier immer alles so einfach
machen aber in der situation auch eine
welle wo die entscheidung ansteht muss
man sich ja irgendwie auch aufeinander
verlassen können und auf die
unterschiedlichen institutionen die eben
dann nach einer entsprechenden
verordnung eine entsprechende aufgabe
haben und ich habe er kritik gekriegt am
anfang von ländern und kommunen die
gesagt haben die anforderungen sind zu
hoch wir müssen hier viel zu viel
kontrollieren das muss doch schnell
gehen so deswegen ist das alles okay was
wird das was man da aus heutiger sicht
sagt akzeptiere ich auch ich will nur
gelegentlich darauf hinweisen dass die
debatte vor eineinviertel jahre eine
etwas andere warten also
zusammenfassend gesagt viel geld ist weg
oder sicht der mensch eine milliarde
laut er gerade einen moment als sich der
menschen die ehrlich ihre steuern zahlen
ist das ein bisschen traurig so könnte
man es vielleicht zusammenfassen aber
ich möchte gerne in einem
größeren zusammenhang stellen in ein
kontinuum deutscher politik der letzten
jahre ganz groß gott sich gesagt die ja
immer durch ein ganz großes maß an
vertrauen in den menschen geprägt war
und darin dass der mensch gut ist und zu
nichts böses im stand ist
so ist es zu 2015 gekommen heute sagen
alle wir wollen das nie wieder dass sich
das wiederholt man hat gedacht egal
menschen ja man hat leute zu wenig
überprüft ja man hat identität nicht
festgestellt hat sich auch auf
lügenmärchen erzählen lassen das wissen
wir ja alle irgendwie kommt mir da ein
bisschen bekannt vor wenn ich das jetzt
mit diesen neueren erlebnissen an den
kreisstellen vergleiche man hat jahres
links heimann könnte man vergleichen
auch von den privaten anbietern
ja genau ja da hat es ja ähnliche
entwicklung gegeben ein anderes beispiel
man war ja fest davon überzeugt dass ein
so reizen der menschen putin zu nichts
böse mit dem stande sein könnte auch das
hat sich als etwas zu naiv
herausgestellt ich will jetzt hier nicht
den besser bisher spielen also ich werde
bestimmt hätte bestimmt auch ganz viele
fehler gemacht
aber es ist auffällig wenn man das so
von außen beobachtet ja ohne zu sagen
ich hätte es besser gemacht ja ganz
bescheiden
fällt aus dassow neuwied und zu viel
vertrauen
in das gut sein des menschen so eine art
grundproblem unseres landes zu sein
scheint
ja also ich muss auch sagen viele haben
sich einfach bereichert an der ganzen
kommune pandemie muss man auch mal sagen
also jetzt auch mit dem test oder wenn
es auch diese masken die ist und was
nicht alles in der presse so umgegangen
ist und ich finde die leute müssen
einfach zur verantwortung gezogen werden
egal wer es jetzt getan hat aber es geht
einfach so nicht und auch sich der
bürger die hier vertreten ist einfach so
dass viele ungerechtigkeiten passiert
sind und klar das leben ist nicht mehr
aber wir können einfach nicht so hängen
gelassen werden viele von uns haben eine
familie existenten verloren viele meiner
kollegen zum beispiel in der
unterhaltungsbranche sie musste
insolvenz anmelden und viele haben auch
selbstmord begangen weil sie einfach mit
dem ganzen druck nicht mehr klarkommen
und dann gibt es da andere die sich dann
einfach daran bereichern und das ist
nicht in ordnung das ist sehr schlimm
und gute übergang zu ihrem thema an sich
ja gerne nur einfach weil dafür betrug
nicht nur da sondern leider auch an
anderen stellen immer bei den
wirtschafts hilfen und dann ja aber dann
sieht man halt mal die einen sagen
wahrscheinlich die nicht so viel hatte
nicht soviel auflagen nicht so viel
papier werden muss man doch schnell und
sie machen gerade für mittelständler für
kleine für selbständige warum müssen die
so viel ausfüllen und nachweisen
überweist denen das geld so war die
stimmung aber leider ja herr martenstein
sind nicht alle menschen gut und gerecht
sondern auch da haben leute dann
betrogen und haben geld erstmal sich
überweisen lassen dass sie nie
zugestanden hätte das ist auch alles ja
dann verfolgt worden aber dann sind die
auflagen erhöht wurden und auf einmal
wurden die november hilfen im märz
glaube ich ausgezahlt weil dann aus der
erfahrung nicht verlassen sondern
kontrollieren dann die verfahren auf
einmal viel komplexer und
anspruchsvoller mangeln
natürlich habe ich will doch einfach nur
mal sagen das ist am ende geht es dann
so ein bisschen um die wahl und mike
ryan von der weko hat das mal speed
beats perfekten genannt in einer krise
geschwindigkeit oder perfektion schnelle
hilfe wirtschaftshilfe in für leute die
es echt schwer hatten die vor
existenzfragen schlagen geschwindelt
oder ja auch nicht jemand der es wurde
halt wurde doch halterner sande hat ich
will dafür an dem beispiel zeigen
wirtschaftshilfen mit dem betrug kam
mehr auflagen und schon dauert es
natürlich länger und und deswegen ist
dass dieser dieser spagat indem sie sind
und das ist einfach noch mal ein
beispiel dafür da habe ich ihn trotzdem
noch eine letzte frage bei meiner these
zu ihrer zeit ständig ist sogar
persönlich wie schwer war es denn sie
haben es ja eben angesprochen man ist
dann kein journalist politiker muss es
machen wie schwer waren das amt war es
auch in manchen zeiten würde
ich habe das gern gemacht so ich hätte
gern weil tatsächlich
regieren unterschied macht und in dieser
pandemie ihr auch immer noch da ist war
das schon für eine besondere
verantwortung verpflichtung zugleich bei
jeder tag immer super natürlich nicht
aber das war es für niemanden in dieser
schwierigen zeit dass das das ist so ich
habe alle alle höhen und tiefen erlebt
in diesen zwei jahren politisch aber
viel wichtiger ist dieses land ist durch
eine echt schwere zeit gegangen und das
hat auch zu zusatz spannungen
zurückgelassener schicksale
zurückgelassen familien die hart
getroffen worden sind und damit in
verantwortung gewesen zu sein dass das
ist ja nicht freude machen oder so das
habe ich einfach auch als das empfunden
weswegen ich mal in die politik gegangen
dass man da im verantwortung übernimmt
auch in schwerin sein